Comment vit un dictateur ?
À quoi ressemble le quotidien
d'un assassin qui détient le pouvoir
de vie et de mort
sur des millions de personnes ?
Quelles sont les habitudes,
les obsessions,
les caprices de ces hommes capables
de plonger tout un peuple,
dans leur folie destructrice ?
Une journée dans la vie d'un dictateur,
propose une immersion dans
l'intimité de 3 des dictateurs,
les plus meurtriers du XXᵉ siècle.
Staline, le dictateur totalitaire,
calculateur froid et méthodique,
Idi Amin Dada, le dictateur impulsif,
brutal et superstitieux.
Mouammar Kadhafi, le richissime tyran,
mégalomane et dépravé.
Nous allons les voir vivre avec
leurs femmes, leurs maîtresses,
leurs complices, leurs assassins.
En pénétrant pour la première fois
dans leur forteresse, leur maison,
leur chambre, au cœur de leur intimité,
nous avons obtenu l'accès
au lieu de leur vie privée,
que nous avons filmé et reconstitué
grâce à des technologies nouvelles.
Et nous y avons intégré des figurants
qui jouent le rôle des dictateurs.
Mais aussi et pour la première fois
dans un documentaire d'histoire,
les dictateurs eux-mêmes,
en les détourant
dans des films d'archives.
Nous avons ainsi recréé
les véritables scènes,
de la vie quotidienne de ces hommes,
dans leur véritable décor.
Ces 3 journées ont été reconstituées
avec le concours d'historiens,
et grâce aux témoignages exclusifs
des proches des dictateurs
et de membres de leurs familles.
- La seule chose qui comptait
pour Staline, c'était le pouvoir.
Un pouvoir total et absolu.
- Kadhafi était un mystère car
il ne faisait confiance à personne.
Ce n'était pas du génie,
c'était de la peur !
- Il avait peur pour sa vie.
Les gens avaient peur de lui.
Et lui aussi avait peur des gens.
Nous allons entrer dans les coulisses
du pouvoir absolu
et nous allons vivre heure par heure,
une journée cruciale de la vie
de ces 3 dictateurs,
à une période charnière de leur règne.
Trois journées décisives,
trois visages de la dictature,
pour comprendre comment la volonté
de puissance d'un seul homme,
peut bouleverser le destin
de tout un peuple.
Union soviétique,
jeudi 24 novembre 1938.
À quelques kilomètres
au sud de Moscou,
le coursier du Kremlin vient livrer
le courrier à la datcha de Staline.
D'une méfiance maladive,
Staline vit retranché
au milieu de la forêt.
La défense de sa résidence est assurée
par des batteries anti-aériennes
et une force de sécurité
de 300 soldats.
Personne n'a le droit de pénétrer
dans la datcha,
sans un ordre express du dictateur.
Seule Valentina, sa gouvernante,
a le droit de s'y déplacer librement.
Comme chaque jour, elle lui
apporte son courrier.
À 7 h du matin, le dictateur
n'est toujours pas couché.
Il a passé la nuit à vérifier
une liste de 3 176 condamnés à mort,
ou à la déportation.
Un travail long et fastidieux
qu'il est loin d'avoir terminé,
car Staline est un homme méticuleux.
Il prend le temps de cocher lui-même
les noms des condamnés un par un.
- C'était un monstre.
Il fonctionnait comme un ordinateur,
qui, après avoir décidé un jour
qu'il aurait le pouvoir absolu,
n'a plus jamais voulu le lâcher.
À 60 ans, au fait de son pouvoir,
il contrôle tout
et mène une vie austère.
Rien ne l'intéresse en dehors
de l'exercice du pouvoir absolu.
- Dans son quotidien, Staline était
extrêmement simple et pas exigeant.
La seule chose qui comptait
pour Staline,
c'était le pouvoir.
Il n'avait besoin de rien d'autre.
Le pouvoir, c'est tout !
Un pouvoir total et absolu !
Staline règne depuis dix ans
sur l'URSS.
Formée de 15 républiques, l'Union des
républiques socialistes soviétiques,
occupe un sixième des terres émergées
et s'étend sur onze fuseaux horaires.
C'est le plus grand empire
de tous les temps.
À ce stade de sa vie,
c'est un homme froid, insensible.
Le nom qu'il a choisi pendant
la Révolution russe, Staline,
signifie l'homme d'acier.
Staline est le dictateur totalitaire
par excellence.
Il est persuadé d'être
l'homme providentiel,
celui qui va transformer la société
pour bâtir un monde idéal,
le communisme.
Il veut créer un homme nouveau.
Un homme discipliné, travailleur
et qui obéit aveuglément au parti,
c'est-à-dire à Staline.
Pour accomplir ce projet colossal,
Staline doit tout détruire
avant de tout reconstruire.
Il faut éradiquer tous les privilèges,
éliminer tous les traîtres
et s'il le faut,
il est prêt à exterminer,
la moitié de la population.
Depuis un an et demi, il a mis en
place un système scientifique,
d'élimination massive
qu'on a appelé la Grande Terreur.
Entre juillet 1937 et ce mois
de novembre 1938,
il a fait exécuter
près de 800 000 Russes,
1 500 victimes par jour,
soit une toutes les 57 secondes.
En cette fin de novembre 1938,
Staline est tout puissant.
Il a exterminé tous ses ennemis,
réels ou imaginaires.
Il est temps d'arrêter le bain de sang,
avant que son peuple ne se rende compte
qu'il n'est qu'un fou meurtrier.
Pour se dédouaner de ses crimes,
Staline va accuser le chef de la
police politique, Nikolaï Iejov,
celui que l'on surnomme
le "nain sanguinaire",
d'avoir outrepassé ses ordres
et commis ces crimes dans son dos.
Iejov qui lui a obéi comme un chien
et qui a lui-même torturé et assassiné
de ses propres mains,
des milliers d'innocents,
va connaître à son tour
la torture et la mort.
Staline l'a convoqué dans son bureau
au Kremlin cet après-midi à 19 h.
Il est 7 h 30 du matin.
Staline a enfin terminé ses
16 h de travail quotidien.
Il s'allonge sur le canapé
de son bureau
et s'endort pour quelques heures,
avant de mettre son plan à exécution.
Comme il le dit lui-même :
"Le plus grand plaisir,
c'est de choisir son ennemi,
préparer son coup,
assouvir sa vengeance,
puis aller se coucher."
Libye, vendredi 28 juin 1996.
Il est 8 h, comme chaque matin,
Mouammar Kadhafi, le guide
de la révolution libyenne,
a du mal à se lever.
Contrairement à l'austérité de Staline,
il est totalement
dominé par ses pulsions
et souffre de nombreuses addictions,
les psychotropes, la c***,
l'alcool et le sexe.
Mais à 54 ans, le corps résiste mal.
Cela fait trop longtemps qu'il
le soumet à toutes sortes d'excès.
La conséquence de ces abus,
c'est qu'il a de plus en plus
de mal à se maîtriser en public.
Son comportement suscite
fréquemment des interrogations.
Mitterrand le jugeait instable.
Ronald Reagan le traitait
de chien enragé.
Et pour Anouar el-Sadate,
il était carrément fou.
C'est pourtant cet homme qui règne
en maître absolu sur la Libye.
Depuis 27 ans, il a systématiquement
pillé toutes les richesses de son pays.
Il a commencé par confisquer les revenus
colossaux du pétrole et du gaz.
Il s'est approprié toutes
les grandes entreprises,
qu'il a redistribué à ses proches.
Mais aujourd'hui,
alors qu'il est l'un des hommes
les plus riches du monde,
il vit dans une maison
à moitié enterrée,
entourée de murs d'enceinte
à l'épreuve des balles
cernées de miradors où des soldats,
font le guet 24 h sur 24.
La maison est non seulement enterrée,
mais elle est cachée à l'intérieur
d'un camp retranché.
Bab al-Azizia.
Un domaine ultra-sécurisé
de six kilomètres carrés.
Un quartier entier
en plein cœur de Tripoli,
de la taille
d'un arrondissement parisien.
Cerné de murailles.
Une véritable forteresse moderne.
Mohammed Gliwan, le cameraman
personnel de Kadhafi,
fait partie du cercle
le plus restreint,
celui des rares personnes qui
vivaient dans l'intimité du dictateur.
- À l'intérieur de la grande
enceinte de Bab al-Azizia,
il y avait une seconde enceinte
et un portail de sécurité,
qui ne laissaient accéder
que certaines personnes.
La famille de Kadhafi,
les proches, moi-même,
le médecin, le cuisinier,
des gens bien précis étaient autorisés
à entrer dans la clôture intérieure,
où se trouvait le Guide suprême.
Et même à l'intérieur
de cette enceinte,
l'emplacement de la maison
est tenu secret.
- Imaginez-vous dans le camp
retranché de Bab al-Azizia,
la plupart des gens ne savaient même
pas où habitait réellement Kadhafi.
Kadhafi était un mystère.
Il ne faisait confiance à personne.
Ce n'était pas du génie,
c'était de la peur.
La peur est devenue
obsessionnelle chez Kadhafi,
depuis que les Américains
ont bombardé son palais en 1986.
Soupçonnée d'être à l'origine
d'attentats t*** à travers le monde,
qui ont fait des centaines de victimes,
il est devenu l'ennemi public
numéro un.
Depuis, il vit en état
de perpétuelle alerte,
comme un fugitif à l'intérieur
de son propre pays.
Mais en cette année 1996,
Kadhafi est menacé
par un nouvel ennemi,
le Front de salut pour
la libération de la Libye,
un groupe armé composé d'islamistes
regroupés dans le désert
et qui lui a déclaré la guerre.
Kadhafi prend la menace au sérieux.
Ce sont des salafistes qu'il soupçonne
d'être liés à Al-Qaïda.
Il en a déjà fait arrêter
des centaines.
Tous regroupés dans la prison
d'Abou Salim.
Les conditions de détention
y sont terribles.
Fathi Saad y était détenu
à cette époque.
Il a connu pendant 12 ans le traitement
que subissait les prisonniers.
- On nous torturait avec des coups,
de l'électricité.
Ils nous accrochaient
aussi les bras en hauteur
et nous laissaient un jour
entier suspendu par les mains.
Et puis la torture continuait.
Ils nous laissaient coucher
tout nus sur le carrelage.
Et ensuite, pendant la nuit,
ils nous versaient de l'eau
bouillante sur le corps.
C'était ça, les différents
types de tortures physiques.
Quand vous étiez emprisonné par Kadhafi,
vous saviez que votre vie était finie.
- Les conditions de vie à l'intérieur
étaient très brutales.
Les cellules étaient surpeuplées.
Lorsque des prisonniers mouraient,
on laissait leurs corps dans
les cellules pendant des jours.
Et la torture était
institutionnalisée.
Les prisonniers avaient l'impression
qu'ils ne sortiraient jamais,
qu'ils étaient enterrés vivants.
Ils avaient le sentiment
d'être dans une prison,
dont les clés avaient été jetées.
En ce vendredi 28 juin 1996,
les prisonniers n'en peuvent plus.
Des cadavres gisent depuis
des jours dans leur cellule.
Ils n'ont plus rien à perdre.
Aujourd'hui, Kadhafi va devoir
faire face à une situation inédite.
En 27 ans de pouvoir absolu,
il n'a jamais eu à faire face
à une rébellion de l'ampleur,
de celle qui se prépare à Abou Salim.
Cette date marquera à jamais,
l'histoire sanglante
de la Libye de Kadhafi.
Ouganda, mardi 26 mars 1974.
Ce matin du mardi 26 mars 1974,
une fois de plus, Amin Dada
vient de faire un cauchemar.
Des tueurs tentaient de l'assassiner
chez lui en pleine nuit.
Et ses tueurs,
c'étaient ses propres soldats.
Comme Kadhafi et Staline,
il dort peu.
Pour ces hommes paranoïaques, la nuit
est le moment de toutes les angoisses,
surtout pour Amin Dada
qui vit dans un monde irrationnel,
où les esprits de ses ennemis
morts viennent le hanter
et ont le pouvoir de se venger.
À cela s'ajoute des peurs bien réelles.
Il y a 3 ans,
il a renversé son prédécesseur
par un coup d'État.
Depuis, il a peur d'être
renversé à son tour.
Pour se maintenir au pouvoir
et se protéger,
il fait régner la terreur
dans tout le pays.
Un simple rêve qu'il croit prémonitoire,
peut déclencher le jour même
des centaines d'arrestations
et d'exécutions.
- Il avait peur pour sa vie
à cause de la façon,
de la façon dont il gouvernait.
Les gens avaient peur de lui
et lui aussi avait peur des gens.
La répression s'exerce sur tout le monde,
à commencer par ses plus
proches collaborateurs
qui disparaissent les uns
après les autres.
Tout le monde en Ouganda :
les membres des forces militaires,
la poilice et le peuple,
tout le monde est responsable
de ma sécurité.
Et dès que quiconque entend
ou voit quelqu'un,
en train de préparer
des activités subversives,
ou en train d'essayer d'organiser
quoi que ce soit contre moi,
il doit le dénoncer
directement à la police.
Et les méthodes de la police d'Amin
sont extrêmement brutales.
Les victimes sont tuées
à coups de massues,
brûlées dans la savane,
leurs corps jetés aux crocodiles du Nil,
fusillés publiquement,
couvertes d'un tablier blanc
pour que le sang se voie mieux.
Ou encore étouffé par
leurs sexes coupés,
enfoncés dans leur gorge
et même dynamités en groupe.
En trois ans, il a déjà fait massacrer,
près de 150 000 Ougandais.
À la différence de Staline et Kadhafi,
Amin s'occupe lui-même
de la répression.
Sa maison est située à quelques
mètres du principal
centre de détention et de torture.
Pour pouvoir s'y rendre sans être vu,
Amin a fait construire un tunnel.
Il torture lui-même ses victimes
et la plupart du temps,
il les achève à coups de massue.
Amin se méfie de tout le monde
et particulièrement de ses proches.
Sa fille se rappelle comment il passait
ses nuits à guetter ses propres soldats.
- Il ne dormait pas beaucoup,
il dormait surtout pendant la journée.
La nuit, il se mettait sur le balcon,
les lumières éteintes,
à surveiller les soldats,
à observer comment ils patrouillaient.
Vous savez dans un endroit
comme State house,
il y a partout des buissons
et beaucoup d'arbres.
C'était normal qu'il ait peur et qu'il
ait même peur de ses propres soldats.
Il était persuadé que n'importe
lequel de ses collaborateurs,
pouvait le renverser.
Et il avait raison.
Parce que ce sont les gens avec qui vous
travaillez qui peuvent vous renverser.
Quand on est président, on ne
peut faire confiance à personne.
On peut aimer ses collaborateurs,
mais on ne peut pas leur
faire confiance.
Comme Staline et Khadafi,
Amin a conquis le pouvoir
par la force.
À partir de là, tous les dictateurs,
rentrent dans la même
spirale de violence.
Ils se méfient de tous,
ils ne peuvent avoir
confiance en personne.
Les plus dangereux sont leurs proches,
ceux qui ont toutes les facilités
pour les assassiner.
Ce danger permanent accentue
leurs tendances paranoïaques
et les fait basculer
progressivement dans la folie.
Et aujourd'hui,
Amin ne le sait pas encore,
mais il a de bonnes raisons
d'avoir peur.
Son propre cousin, le général Arube,
avec qui il a grandi et qu'il a
lui-même nommé chef des armées,
est sur le point de le renverser.
Comme il le racontera plus tard
à son fils, Jaffar Amin,
il se prépare à vivre la journée
la plus difficile de son règne.
- La tentative de putsch,
organisée par sa propre
ethnie, les Kakwa,
car nous sommes des Kakwa,
a été l'événement le plus douloureux
qu'ait connu mon père.
Charles Arube était comme un frère.
C'était plus qu'un simple cousin,
c'était vraiment un frère.
Aujourd'hui, Amin va devoir
franchir une nouvelle étape.
Pour la première fois, il va
s'attaquer à sa propre famille.
Il est 10 h,
Staline a dormi à peine 3 h.
Malgré son immense popularité,
le petit père des peuples,
adulé dans le monde entier,
vit comme un loup solitaire
dans son immense datcha.
La villa comprend plusieurs salons,
une dizaine de chambres,
des pièces vides où il ne met
jamais les pieds.
Depuis le suicide de sa femme
il y a six ans,
Staline s'est totalement isolé.
Alors qu'il vivait entouré de
ses amis et de sa belle famille,
aujourd'hui, il n'a plus confiance
qu'en une seule personne,
sa servante, Valentina.
C'est elle qui prend soin
de Staline au quotidien.
D'une fidélité absolue.
Illettrée, naïve,
toujours de bonne humeur,
elle partage secrètement
le lit du dictateur.
Une liaison qui durera
jusqu'à la mort de Staline.
- Elle faisait tout à la maison.
C'est elle qui changeait
le lit de Staline,
qui lavait ses vêtements,
qui le servait à table.
Elle faisait tout ce qu'elle
pouvait pour lui.
Valentina est la seule à connaître
toutes les faiblesses du dictateur.
Car derrière l'image
du chef invulnérable,
Staline est un homme
à la santé fragile,
souffrant d'angine chronique,
de psoriasis,
d'athérosclérose qui nécessite
des soins quotidiens.
- Staline était un homme
de petite taille.
Il avait une main handicapée
car pendant son enfance,
il avait eu un accident.
Il était tombé sous
un tramway et donc,
son bras était toujours
un peu plié,
ce qui le complexait.
Et puis il avait une peau grêlée,
encore une fois les conséquences
d'une maladie,
qu'il avait eu dans son enfance.
Elle aimait Staline passionnément.
Elle l'aimait à la folie.
Et apparemment,
elle était son type de femme.
C'était la beauté russe classique.
Elle avait des fesses bien rondes,
une longue natte blonde
et elle aimait bien rire.
Elle avait dû avorter plusieurs fois.
Tout le monde savait
qui était le père.
Elle disparaissait
pendant trois jours,
puis elle revenait
comme si de rien n'était.
Aujourd'hui, Staline
vit seul avec Valentina,
mais auparavant,
il s'est marié deux fois.
Sa première femme est morte
de maladie, très jeune.
Sa deuxième femme, Nadia,
a eu deux enfants avec Staline.
Lorsqu'elle était vivante,
les deux belles familles,
venaient souvent à la datcha
faire des pique-niques.
C'était une époque joyeuse.
Mais en 1932, Nadia se suicide,
d'un coup de revolver dans le cœur.
Après treize ans de mariage,
elle avait progressivement découvert,
qui était réellement l'homme
qu'elle avait épousé.
- Elle s'est mise à comprendre
des choses sur lui,
car autour d'elle,
les gens ont commencé à disparaître.
Elle n'était pas idiote.
Elle a compris que ce n'était
pas un homme aussi simple
et aussi ouvert qu'il avait
pu le paraître au début.
Nadia a gardé ses souffrances
secrètes jusqu'à la fin,
par loyauté pour son mari.
Mais avant de se suicider,
elle s'est confiée à son frère
et à sa belle-sœur,
les parents d'Alexandre.
- Avant de se suicider,
Nadia avait laissé
une lettre à mes parents.
Elle disait qu'elle ne pouvait plus
continuer à vivre avec Staline,
mais qu'elle n'avait
nulle part où aller,
car il la retrouverait partout.
En parlant du suicide de sa femme,
Staline disait :
"Elle m'a quittée comme une ennemie.
Elle m'a laissé infirme pour la vie."
- Staline considérait que Nadia,
l'avait abandonné
alors qu'il l'aimait.
Pour lui, son suicide était
une véritable trahison.
À partir de ce moment,
Staline s'est complètement renfermé.
Il a réussi à digérer
la mort de sa femme,
mais sa vie n'a plus
jamais été la même.
C'est cet événement qui a fait perdre
définitivement à Staline,
tout sentiment humain.
Il commence alors à développer une
véritable haine contre toute sa famille,
qu'il éliminera systématiquement.
- En parlant du caractère
de Joseph Staline,
sa femme disait qu'il avait
une double personnalité
et qu'il était capable d'écraser
tout le monde, y compris vous.
C'est ce qu'elle disait
dans sa lettre.
Et c'est précisément cet après-midi,
en cette journée de novembre 1938,
qu'Evguénia
la mère d'Alexandre,
va commettre l'erreur
qui lui sera fatale.
Il est 11 h à Bab al-Azizia.
Kadhafi est en train de se préparer
dans sa salle de bain.
Plusieurs jeunes femmes se relaient
pour s'occuper de lui en permanence.
Elles vérifient chaque matin
sa tension artérielle.
Elles le massent, le maquillent.
et lui teignent les cheveux
pour masquer sa calvitie.
Mais à 54 ans, Kadhafi ne supporte plus,
le vieillissement prématuré de son visage
marqué par toutes sortes d'excès
qui n'a plus rien à voir avec
celui du jeune homme qu'il était,
lorsqu'il a pris le pouvoir
25 ans plus tôt.
À l'époque, la presse
internationale l'avait surnommé,
le Kennedy arabe.
Et cette image de jeune premier,
avait été un élément essentiel
de sa popularité et de son succès.
Mais aujourd'hui, il ne peut plus
compter sur cette arme de séduction.
Il y a quelques semaines,
il a subi sa première opération
de chirurgie esthétique.
Elle a eu lieu en plein
milieu de la nuit,
dans une clinique ultra-sécurisée
construite sous sa maison,
dans un bunker.
Le chirurgien était brésilien.
Aucun Libyen n'était présent
et Kadhafi a refusé
une anesthésie générale,
pour rester conscient
pendant l'opération.
- Dans le palais, je n'ai vu aucun
Libyen, c'était tous des étrangers.
La majorité est d'origine slave,
des Russes, des Yougoslaves.
Et puis des Pakistanais, des Indiens,
mais des Libyens à l'intérieur du
bunker, je n'en ai jamais rencontré.
Qui a tué Indira Gandhi ?
C'était un Indien.
Qui a tué Sadate ? C'était un Égyptien.
Il avait peur qu'un Libyen le tue.
C'est pour ça qu'il n'y avait pas
de Libyens dans le bunker.
C'est aussi pour ça qu'il n'a pas voulu
qu'on lui fasse d'anesthésie générale.
Toute sa vie,
Kadhafi continuera à faire des
opérations de chirurgie esthétique,
sans anesthésie générale.
Obsédée par son image,
Kadhafi s'invente sans cesse
de nouveaux personnages,
en fonction des rôles politiques
qu'il aimerait incarner.
Soldats de la révolution.
Parrain du terrorisme international.
Leader autoproclamé des pays arabes.
Et même roi des rois d'Afrique.
Son arrogance et sa mégalomanie
n'ont plus de limites.
- Vraiment, c'était un emmerdeur.
Il cherchait à se faire remarquer
par tout le monde et à tout prix.
Comme dit un proverbe de chez nous,
sois provoquant et tu seras connu.
Quand il s'habillait
de manière extravagante,
la presse s'intéressait à lui,
c'est tout.
Il a même fait voyager des dromadaires
par avion en Yougoslavie.
C'était juste pour le show, pour
que les médias s'intéressent à lui.
C'est un homme qui avait
un sentiment de frustration,
un complexe d'infériorité
qu'il compensait par sa mégalomanie.
Peut-être que la pauvreté
qu'il a vécue dans son enfance,
lui a causé
des complexes psychologiques,
qui se sont développés par la suite.
Il a connu une période très difficile
et a cherché à se venger sur son peuple.
Et moi, je l'ai vu exercer
cette vengeance tous les jours.
Kadhafi vient d'une famille de bédouins
qui vivait sous une tente,
dans une zone désertique
près de la ville de Syrte,
une région considérée
comme quasi inhabitable,
où le jeune Mouammar
gardait des chèvres.
Son père était serviteur
pour une famille puissante.
Ils étaient considérés comme
des Libyens de seconde zone.
Kadhafi ne l'oubliera jamais.
Son cousin Said Gadafeldman,
a partagé son enfance misérable.
En ce temps-là, les tribus
respectaient la force
et la richesse.
Et lui n'était ni fort ni riche.
Il a eu une vie difficile au début.
Je pense que c'est l'une des raisons,
qui l'ont dressée plus tard
contre les gens.
Contre toute la société.
C'est très profond chez lui.
C'est ce qui constitue sa personnalité.
Alors qu'il n'a que dix ans,
Kadhafi décide de quitter
la misère dans laquelle il vit,
pour aller étudier à la ville.
Il monte dans un camion et arrive
à Syrte, seul, démuni,
il dort dehors et se nourrit de dattes.
Lorsqu'il revient dans son désert
quelques années plus tard,
c'est en héros.
Il est devenu le colonel Kadhafi,
l'homme qui vient de faire la révolution
et de libérer son peuple,
en faisant tomber la monarchie
du vieux roi Idriss,
au pouvoir depuis 52 ans.
Et dès le début, Kadhafi a su mettre
en scène cette enfance difficile.
Il fait participer sa famille
à des reportages,
retransmis à la télévision libyenne,
repris par les chaînes étrangères,
où il joue à l'homme modeste qui
doit tout à sa force de caractère
et à son courage.
- Enfant, j'étais berger
et j'emmenais paître,
les troupeaux de moutons et de brebis.
Je me souviens de la pauvreté dans
laquelle se trouvait toute la région.
- Moi et son oncle,
nous étions bergers.
J'ai délaissé les études
pour devenir berger.
Tout le monde poussait Mouammar
à arrêter ses études
et à venir aider sa famille
qui vivait dans la misère.
Il a refusé et a continué à étudier.
25 ans plus tard,
Kadhafi et sa famille,
contrôlent toutes les raffineries
et sont à la tête de toutes
les grandes entreprises du pays.
Ce n'est qu'après sa mort que son peuple
découvrira que le modeste Bédouin
et ses enfants vivaient
dans le plus grand luxe.
À la fin de sa vie,
sa fortune personnelle sera évaluée
à 144 milliardsde dollars.
Le petit berger du désert est devenu
l'un des hommes les plus riches du monde.
Amin Dada, lui aussi, a pillé son pays.
Il collectionne les voitures de luxe
et dépense sans compter.
Il n'est presque jamais
dans son bureau
et passe beaucoup de temps
dans ses villas,
entouré de maîtresses.
- Il avait tellement de femmes.
Dans la plupart des maisons qu'il avait,
il devait toujours y avoir une femme.
On estime que Amin Dada était
le père d'au moins 40 enfants.
Mais même Babby Salamshyda, la fille
d'une de ces trois femmes légitimes,
ne peut se souvenir du nombre exact
de ses frères et sœurs.
- On habitait avec six plus quatre,
celui qui est mort et puis
encore quatre et huit.
Je dirais...
Je crois qu'on était 22.
Après trois années de pouvoir absolu,
Amin peut enfin obtenir tout ce dont
il a été privé dans son enfance.
- Mon père venait du rang
le plus bas de la société.
Il nous disait toujours : "J'étais
un simple coupeurs de canne à sucre.
Je travaillais dans les champs
quand j'étais enfant et de là,
je suis arrivé
jusqu'à la tête de l'État.
Si je l'ai fait,
c'est que c'est possible."
Il a vécu l'époque coloniale.
Et alors qu'il sortait de nulle part,
il a réussi à prendre le pouvoir.
Mais il avait subi
et connu l'époque coloniale.
Amin vient de la tribu des Kakwa,
aux confins de l'Ouganda,
dans un désert aride.
Son père quitte sa famille alors
qu'il est encore très jeune.
Sa mère pratique la sorcellerie.
Elle élève seule son fils
dans un monde irrationnel,
dominé par les esprits.
Pour survivre, elle se met
en ménage avec un soldat,
de l'armée coloniale anglaise.
Mais elle subit les railleries
des autres soldats de la caserne,
qui finissent par les chasser,
elle et son fils.
Ils vont vivre dans la misère,
jusqu'au jour où Amin n'aura
d'autre choix que de s'engager
dans cette même armée qu'il a humilié.
À 18 ans, il est simple
aide cuisinier,
mais il gravit très vite les échelons.
En quelques années, il devient
l'un des seuls officiers noirs,
de l'armée coloniale, qui a su
reconnaître sa violence sans limite.
Chargé de mater les révoltes
des tribus rebelles,
Amin utilise la terreur et la torture.
- Une des méthodes qu'il utilisait,
c'était de couper les parties
génitales des rebelles
pour les humilier.
Après l'indépendance et le départ
des Anglais en 1962,
Amin poursuit son ascension
et devient général en chef des armées
du président Milton Obote.
Mais son ambition ne s'arrête pas là.
Après avoir tenté plusieurs
fois de l'assassiner,
il réussira finalement à le renverser
et s'empare du pouvoir
le 25 janvier 1971.
Idi Amin n'était pas très éduqué.
Il n'était pas allé loin à l'école,
mais il était très intelligent.
Il avait une intelligence naturelle.
Et il a réussi à faire son chemin,
à la grande surprise
de ceux qui l'entouraient.
Désormais, c'est Amin
qui détient le pouvoir.
- Président, vous avez déclaré que vous
vouliez donner une leçon aux anglais,
est-ce que cela signifie la fin
de l'amitié avec la Grande-Bretagne ?
- Donner une leçon aux Anglais,
c'est ce que je fais.
Avec ironie, il se livre à des
provocations pour humilier,
à son tour ses anciens maîtres.
Il oblige les hommes d'affaires anglais
à lui faire allégeance à genoux.
Et se fait promener sur un trône
par quatre hommes blancs.
Il ira même jusqu'à s'attribuer des
décorations de l'armée britannique.
Afin que les choses soient
bien claires pour vous,
j'ai été honoré de la
plus haute décoration
en tant que conquérant de l'impérialisme
britannique en Ouganda.
Amin s'invente les titres
les plus fantaisistes.
Il se proclame président à vie,
roi d'Écosse et sa mégalomanie
prenant des proportions délirantes,
Seigneurs de tous les animaux du monde
et de tous les poissons des mers.
1m95, 125 kilos.
Amin Dada est une véritable
force de la nature,
un colosse qui impressionne
tout le monde.
Son physique hors du commun
et son sens du spectacle,
l'ont rendu très populaire.
Dès le début, les caméras du monde
se sont tournées vers cet individu,
excentrique et imprévisible,
capable de donner une interview
dans sa piscine en pyjama.
- Je fais les deux,
de la politique et du sport.
Et les techniques que j'utilise dans
le sport pour mettre les gens KO,
je les utilise aussi en politique.
Dans sa jeunesse, il a remporté 8 fois
le titre de champion de boxe d'Ouganda.
Amin est l'homme le plus fort du pays.
Il est le Big Daddy qui rassure
et effraie à la fois.
Car si ses excentricités amusent
son peuple et les médias,
elles servent surtout d'écran
de fumée à ses crimes.
Il est 12 h 30.
Amin vient d'apprendre une nouvelle
qui le rend furieux.
Ses trois femmes ont fait la fête
toute la nuit avec leurs gardes du corps,
délaissées par leur mari,
elles ont voulu le provoquer,
mais elles n'ont pas mesuré
le risque qu'elles prenaient.
Amin ne supporte pas l'affront
et décide de se venger.
Il se précipite à la radio
pour révéler à tout le pays,
le comportement indécent de ses femmes.
Il vocifère :
"Mes femmes ne sont pas fidèles.
Elles m'ont trahi.
Elles détruisent tout mon travail
politique. Je les répudie.
Je divorce aujourd'hui même,
elles doivent quitter la maison.
En entendant ces déclarations,
les 3 femmes ont fait leurs
valises dans la précipitation,
pour fuir la colère d'Amin.
En rentrant de l'école, les enfants
ne comprennent pas ce qu'il se passe.
- Je me souviens,
on rentrait de l'école
et quand on est arrivé à la maison,
on a découvert la situation.
Notre mère et nos belles-mères
n'étaient plus là.
On a demandé aux domestiques :
"Où sont nos mamans ?"
Ils ont répondu : "Elles ont fait
leurs bagages et elles sont parties."
Ça nous a fait un choc.
On ne pouvait rien
demander à notre père,
parce qu'il nous regardait
sans rien dire.
On avait vraiment peur de lui demander.
Oui, c'est ça.
On rentrait de l'école.
Quelques mois plus tard, Malayamu,
la mère de Babby, est victime
d'un accident au cours duquel,
elle est grièvement blessée.
Elle réussit à fuir l'Ouganda
et se réfugie à Londres.
Sa fille ne la reverra pas
pendant plus de 30 ans.
Nora sera épargnée pour
des raisons politiques.
Elle fait partie d'une tribu
qu'Amin persécute.
Il la préserve pour pouvoir dire
qu'il n'est pas responsable.
Kai aura moins de chance.
Elle est retrouvée un an plus tard,
découpée en morceaux dans une voiture.
Les enfants ont appris le drame
par la télévision.
- On était en train de jouer dehors
et on nous a appelés pour la douche.
Et puis nos sœurs sont arrivées pour
nous dire de venir regarder la télé.
"Mama Kay est morte !"
Alors ma sœur, la fille aînée de
Mama Kay, a commencé à pleurer.
Sa mère avait été découpée en morceaux.
C'était dur,
c'était très dur pour nous.
C'était quelque chose d'étrange.
C'est le ministre de la Santé lui-même
qui a dû, sur les ordres d'Amin,
faire recoudre le corps de la victime.
Il a demandé que les parties du corps
soient recousues comme il faut.
Et c'est ce qu'on a fait à l'hôpital.
Et les enfants ont dû aller
voir le corps de leur mère.
C'était une expérience traumatisante
pour des enfants de cet âge-là.
Amin profitera de l'occasion pour
organiser une mise en scène macabre.
Il fera exposer le corps recousu
de Kay devant l'hôpital,
sous les yeux de la foule,
et forcera même ses propres
enfants à le regarder.
Devant tout le monde, il s'écrie :
"Votre mère était une femme
de mauvaise vie.
Regardez ce qui arrive.
Ainsi sont punis ceux
qui ont blasphémé Allah.
Babby Salamshyda se souvient
encore du moment où elle a vu,
ses demi-frères et sœurs
rentrés de l'hôpital.
Ils pleuraient,
ils étaient très malheureux.
Ils ne voulaient plus jouer avec nous.
Ils disaient que leur maman
leur manquait.
Ils disaient :
"Nous, on n'a plus de mère,
alors que vous,
vous avez encore la vôtre."
Il est 13 h.
Staline reçoit dans son bureau
Evguénia, sa belle-sœur,
qui est venue le voir à l'improviste.
Evguénia est la sœur
de sa deuxième femme, Nadia,
celle qui s'est suicidée.
Depuis cet événement tragique,
Staline déteste toute sa belle famille.
Il reçoit Evguénia froidement.
Evguénia a peur.
Staline a déjà envoyé au goulag ou à
la mort une partie de sa famille proche.
Elle le soupçonne même
de l'empoisonnement de son mari,
quelques jours plus tôt.
Pourtant, malgré le danger,
elle vient lui remettre
une lettre de Maria,
une autre des belles-sœurs de Staline,
qu'il a envoyée au goulag,
sans raison apparente.
Les conditions de vie dans les goulags
de Staline en Sibérie sont terribles.
Jusqu'à -50 degrés l'hiver,
15 h de travail par jour,
une nourriture insuffisante.
On y mourait de froid, de faim,
de maladie, d'épuisement
et de désespoir.
De son goulag, Maria a réussi
à faire parvenir une lettre,
à sa belle-sœur pour supplier
Staline de la libérer.
Elle écrit :
"Si je ne quitte pas ce camp,
j'en mourrai."
Bien des années plus tard,
Evguénia a raconté à Alexandre,
son fils, la scène.
- Staline a lu la lettre,
puis a demandé à ma mère de ne plus
jamais lui demander ce genre de choses.
Il n'a pas hurlé ou tapé du poing,
mais vu la manière dont il lui a dit ça,
ma mère avait compris qu'il ne lui
pardonnerait pas cet acte malheureux.
En effet, Staline déteste qu'on
plaide la cause de gens,
qu'il a classé une fois pour
toutes comme ses ennemis.
Non seulement Maria
ne sera pas libérée,
mais elle sera transférée
dans un camp encore plus dur
et sera exécutée quelques mois
plus tard.
Quant à Evguénia,
en guise de représailles,
Staline, qui n'oublie jamais une offense,
l'enverra, elle aussi, au goulag.
Presque toute la famille de Staline
sera victime de sa folie meurtrière.
Pavel, frère de Nadia,
sa deuxième femme,
empoisonné le 2 novembre 1938.
Evguénia, sa femme et Kira, leur fille,
envoyées au goulag en 1947.
Anna, la sœur aînée de la première
femme de Staline,
six ans de goulag.
Son mari Stanislav,
fusillé le 12 février 1940.
Alexandre, frère de sa première femme,
fusillé le 20 août 1941.
Sa femme, Maria, est la sœur
de celle-ci, Mariko,
fusillées ensemble en mars 1942.
Sans compter tous ses amis proches,
qui ont disparu
les uns après les autres.
- Il y a tyrannie et tyrannie.
Mais tout de même.
Envoyer sa propre famille en prison.
Je considère que c'est...
Staline lui-même a grandi
dans une famille,
où régnait l'insécurité et la violence.
Il est le seul survivant
de trois enfants.
Son père, cordonnier, était alcoolique
et tabassait régulièrement son fils.
Il meurt lorsque Staline a dix ans.
Sa mère, femme de ménage, remarque
très tôt son intelligence
et réussit à l'inscrire dans
un collège pour devenir prêtre.
Élève brillant,
il fera huit ans d'études,
mais sera renvoyé à cause
de ses idées subversives.
Il vient de découvrir le marxisme.
Il s'engage alors farouchement dans la
lutte révolutionnaire contre le tsar.
Staline assassine de ses propres mains
et devient le chef d'une bande de
bolcheviks qui braquent les banques,
pillent les villages
et organisent des attentats,
pour financer le parti de Lénine.
Lorsque les bolcheviks
prennent le pouvoir,
Lénine en fera l'un
des hauts cadres du parti.
Pourtant, avant de mourir,
il écrira :
Staline est beaucoup trop brutal.
Il faut l'empêcher de prendre le pouvoir.
8 ans plus tard, c'est Staline
qui règne sur l'Union soviétique.
D'un point de vue clinique,
Joseph Staline,
Amin Dada et Mouammar Kadhafi,
ont tous les trois
les caractéristiques du psychopathe.
Ils ont souffert de la violence,
de la misère et des humiliations,
qu'ils ont subi dans leur enfance
et ont développé
un profond rejet social.
Ils ont aussi souffert
de l'absence de père,
absence physique pour Staline et Amin
qui l'ont perdu très tôt.
Absence symbolique pour Kadhafi,
fils d'un homme faible et humilié.
Quand le psychopathe va de plus
en plus loin dans sa folie,
il cherche les limites que son père
n'a pas pu lui imposer.
Et infliger la mort
à des milliers de personnes,
est le moyen ultime
de dépasser les limites.
Comme Staline,
Kadhafi signent chaque jour,
des listes de condamnés
à la prison ou la mort.
Ils ne tolèrent aucune contestation.
Ils disaient : "Les opposants, et tout
particulièrement les islamistes,
doivent être traités comme les cafards
et méritent d'être éradiqués
sans être jugés.
- Tous les jours,
on lui apportait une feuille avec
la liste des noms des personnes
qui avaient été arrêtés.
Et en fonction de son humeur,
il décidait d'en libérer certaines
et d'en garder d'autres.
Il était juge, policier, président.
Il était tout.
Dès son arrivée au pouvoir,
il a mis en place un régime
de répression brutale.
Mais c'est en 1984, après avoir
échappé de justesse à un attentat,
qu'il décide de retransmettre
à la télévision des procès
et des exécutions publiques pour
terrifier toute la population.
Le premier de ces procès fut
celui de ce jeune étudiant.
Jugé devant une foule déchaînée
et dont le seul tort,
est d'être allé étudier à l'étranger.
Un pseudo tribunal l'accuse
d'avoir pris contact,
avec des opposants aux États-Unis.
Et même d'avoir été entraîné au Maroc,
pour préparer un attentat
contre Kadhafi.
Dans l'espoir de sauver sa tête,
l'étudiant avoue tout
ce qu'on lui reproche.
Mais comme dans tous
les procès truqués,
la fin est inexorable.
- C'est un événement qui a
choqué tous les Libyens.
Parce que c'est à ce moment-là
qu'ils ont compris,
jusqu'où le régime de Kadhafi
était prêt à aller,
pour répandre la terreur
au sein de son propre peuple.
Toute la population se sent menacée,
même les personnalités
les plus haut placés.
- C'était comme ça. Celui qui
s'opposait à Mouammar Kadhafi,
était soumis à des humiliations,
à la prison,
à la torture et même à la mort.
Pourtant, Kadhafi a été
un jeune révolutionnaire,
qui a pris le pouvoir à 27 ans
pour défendre de grands idéaux,
bâtir l'unité des pays arabes,
libérer la Libye de l'occupation
étrangère en nationalisant le pétrole
et rendre à la patrie
son indépendance et sa fierté.
Les Libyens voyaient en lui le grand
libérateur, l'héritier de Nasser.
Comme Staline et Amin Dada,
le sentiment de fierté nationale
et une plus grande justice sociale,
sont les deux leviers dont il s'est
servi pour asseoir son pouvoir.
- Tous, j'en suis convaincu,
hommes, femmes, jeunes, vieux,
ont à l'époque marché
derrière Mouammar Kadhafi.
Il est venu avec des valeurs.
Le bonheur, le bien,
l'amour des autres.
C'étaient des idées humanistes.
Et tout le monde s'est engagé
derrière Mouammar Kadhafi.
Mais la lune de miel avec
son peuple est bien terminée.
Aujourd'hui,
il a peur de ses concitoyens.
Il ne supporte plus qu'on le touche.
Lorsqu'il est obligé de se livrer aux
traditionnels bains de foule,
tout en faisant semblant
de communier avec elle,
il frappe ses gardes du corps
s'ils laissent les gens,
s'approcher trop près de lui.
- Oui, il frappait ses propres gardes,
même avec les pieds, en les menaçant,
il leur disait :
"Je t'en ferai voir,
espèce de chien !"
- Quand on lui prenait la main,
il avait peur qu'on le tue.
Alors, il frappait ses gardes
pour éloigner la foule.
Et plus la foule s'approchait de lui
et plus il tapait sur ses gardes.
Kadhafi a perdu tout
contact avec son peuple.
Il ne communique plus
qu'à travers la télévision.
Aujourd'hui,
comme plusieurs fois par semaine,
il se prépare à enregistrer l'un
de ses interminables discours,
dont il assomme les Libyens.
Mais alors qu'il est
enfin prêt à commencer,
son secrétaire lui annonce
qu'une révolte vient d'éclater,
dans la prison d'Abou Salim.
Kadhafi ne prend pas
l'alerte au sérieux.
Abou Salim est un pénitencier
ultra-sécurisé
et il fait confiance à sa
puissante police politique,
pour mater la rébellion.
Mais ce qui est en train
de se passer dans la prison,
est bien plus grave
que ce qu'il croit.
- C'était le vendredi, vers 13 h,
pendant la distribution de nourriture,
que la révolte a commencé.
Dans le bâtiment 4,
il y avait des prisonniers morts.
Ils avaient été laissés
dans les cellules,
pour impressionner
les autres prisonniers.
Leur odeur empestait.
Alors, quand un garde a ouvert
la porte d'une cellule,
les prisonniers se sont jetés sur lui.
Ils l'ont assommé et ont pris ses clés.
Kadhafi ne soupçonne pas
qu'à cet instant précis,
l'événement qui est en train
de se produire,
aura des répercussions
jusqu'au jour de sa mort.
Après avoir divorcé ce matin
de ses trois femmes,
Amin doit affronter son cousin,
le général Charles Arube.
Il veut le voir en face pour lire dans
ses yeux s'il est vraiment déterminé
à le trahir comme on
le lui a rapporté.
Arube incarne tout ce qu'il déteste.
C'est un homme élégant et cultivé,
un intellectuel,
qui a fait ses études en Angleterre.
Pour Amin, il représente
une menace réelle,
car il a le soutien d'une grande
partie de l'armée régulière.
La situation est d'autant
plus délicate,
qu'il s'agit de quelqu'un
de sa famille.
Amin attaque directement Arube.
Il lui annonce qu'il est
au courant du complot
et qu'il ne compte pas
se laisser faire.
Mais Arube ne paraît pas impressionné.
Il ne cherche pas à se défendre
et se permet même de critiquer
le régime de terreur,
dans lequel Amin a plongé le pays.
Amin explose de colère.
Personne n'a jamais osé
le défier comme ça.
C'est lui le chef maintenant.
Et si Arube le critique
une fois de plus,
il est prêt à le faire
exécuter sur le champ.
Mais Arube reste impassible.
Amin comprend que son cousin
est vraiment déterminé
et qu'il a peut-être sous-estimé
les forces dont il dispose.
Il n'a pas le choix,
il va devoir se débarrasser de lui.
Alors, il change d'attitude
et fait semblant de vouloir
apaiser la situation.
Il lui dit : "Tu es mon frère.
Un Kakwa comme moi.
Faisons la paix.
Pars tranquille
et que Dieu te protège."
Les 2 hommes ont fait semblant
de se réconcilier,
mais ils savent que l'affrontement
est inévitable
et qu'il aboutira à la mort
de l'un des deux.
À peine Arube sorti de son bureau,
Amin convoque le chef
de ses mercenaires.
Il lui ordonne de réunir ses hommes
et de se lancer à la poursuite
d'Arube pour l'assassiner.
Si Amin lui-même leur donnait
l'ordre de vous éliminer,
ils pouvaient le faire n'importe où,
devant tout le monde,
Il ne se gênait pas.
Comme tous les jours
en début d'après-midi,
Staline travaille
dans son bureau du Kremlin.
Cette petite pièce
est le centre de l'Empire.
Depuis les 4 coins du pays,
des millions de fonctionnaires
font remonter,
la moindre information
jusqu'au dictateur.
Seul au sommet de l'immense
pyramide administrative,
Staline sait tout, il est omnipotent.
Pour l'assister
dans ce travail colossal,
il dispose de 4 secrétaires
disponibles 24 h sur 24.
Staline procède toujours
de la même façon.
- Alors, je montais frapper à sa porte
et c'est Staline
lui-même qui m'ouvrait.
Il me disait : "Camarade,
nous allons travailler
ensemble aujourd'hui."
Il tirait toujours la chaise
devant moi en disant :
"Asseyez-vous,
je vais vous dicter mon texte."
Ensuite, il me demandait :
"Camarade, dans combien de temps
ce sténogramme, sera-t-il prêt ?"
Moi, je répondais :
"Dans 40 minutes."
On ne pouvait pas se tromper
d'une virgule ou d'une lettre.
Si on faisait des fautes
ou si on s'exprimait mal,
on était viré sur le champ.
Mais les listes de condamnés,
Staline les examine seul, en secret.
Le personnel du Politburo ne doit
pas savoir que c'est lui,
le responsable du massacre
de milliers d'innocents.
Il raye un nom de temps en temps,
celui d'un camarade ayant
partagé l'exil en Sibérie,
lorsqu'il était jeune révolutionnaire,
ou celui d'un vieux bolchevik
géorgien comme lui.
Pour les autres, une simple
croix dans la marge,
suffit à les envoyer à la mort.
Dans cette liste, Staline coche
aussi le nom de personnes,
qui travaillent à cet instant même
de l'autre côté du couloir.
- Dans le comité central
où je travaillais,
tous les jours, je voyais qu'on changeait
les noms des gens sur les portes.
Tel ou tel chef était remplacé.
On arrivait un matin
et ils n'étaient simplement plus là.
On demandait pourquoi.
"Arrêtez,
c'était un ennemi du peuple !"
Et on y croyait tous.
Un jour, ils sont venus
chez nous arrêter mon mari.
Quand ils l'ont emmené,
j'ai couru derrière lui
et je lui ai posé une seule question :
"Chéri, toi aussi,
tu es un ennemi alors ?"
Et il m'a répondu :
"Je suis totalement innocent.
Ne t'inquiète pas, je reviendrai
et je te retrouverai."
C'est la dernière fois que je l'ai vu.
J'ai su bien plus tard
qu'il avait été fusillé,
six mois après.
Deux mois après l'arrestation
de mon mari,
j'ai été arrêtée à mon tour.
L'inspecteur qui m'interrogeait,
m'a humiliée,
m'a violée et m'a frappée.
Vous voyez, j'ai encore
une bosse sur mon front,
qui me le rappelle.
Ce sont les traces de la ceinture
avec laquelle il me frappait.
Après toutes ces années, j'ai
encore les traces de ses coups.
Tous les collaborateurs de Staline
parcourent le pays,
pour s'assurer que les condamnations
sont bien exécutées.
Une manière pour Staline
d'en faire des complices.
Ils ne pourront plus l'accuser de crimes
dont ils ont été eux-mêmes coupables.
Anastase Mikoyan, l'un des principaux
ministres de Staline,
est l'un d'entre eux.
Son fils se souvient.
- On ne se rend plus compte aujourd'hui
à quel point c'était horrible.
Vous imaginez, on vous donne une liste
sans explication, sans faits, rien.
Juste le nom des gens et une seule
indication "à exécuter".
Les familles des condamnés devaient
elles aussi être éliminées.
- Vous imaginez, c'est lui qui
a été à l'origine d'une loi,
pendant la Grande Terreur
qui permettait de fusiller
les gens à partir de 14 ans.
Des enfants de 15-16 ans fusillés.
Est-ce qu'une personne normale
est capable de faire ça ?
Non, c'est un monstre !
Nous sommes le jeudi 24 novembre 1938,
Staline vient de signer la dernière
liste de condamnés à mort,
de la Grande Terreur.
Il lui reste une dernière
chose à faire,
désigner celui qui devra
endosser la responsabilité,
de tous ces crimes.
Alors que la révolte
de la prison d'Abou Salim,
qui a débuté 3 h plus tôt, s'amplifie,
Kadhafi n'a toujours pas pris conscience
de la gravité de la situation.
Il retourne dans sa chambre où
l'attend une de ses victimes.
Elles viennent de tous les milieux
de la société.
Elles sont enlevées
et amenées auprès du guide,
sans que personne
ne puisse s'y opposer.
Elles sont abusées,
soumises aux pires humiliations
et souvent battues.
Dès 1983, Kadhafi a créé une académie
militaire réservée aux femmes,
qu'il a appelé "ses Amazones".
Elles sont censées incarner
l'image de la Libye moderne
et de son guide libérateur des femmes.
Elles forment sa garde rapprochée
et l'entourent dans tous
ses déplacements publics.
En fait, ces Amazones constituent
un gigantesque harem,
de plus de 400 jeunes femmes
au service du dictateur.
Mais cela ne lui suffit pas.
- Quand il rencontrait
une fille qui lui plaisait,
lors d'une sortie ou d'un événement,
il posait sa main sur son épaule.
C'était un signal qu'il donnait
à son entourage.
- Dès qu'il posait sa main
sur une fille,
une amazone entrait en contact avec
elle et prenait son numéro de téléphone.
La grande majorité des filles qui
ont été amenées à Bab al-Azizia,
l'ont été par ordre direct de Kadhafi,
juste en ayant posé la main sur elle
dans n'importe quelle situation.
Étudiante à l'université ou pendant
une visite à une famille,
c'est comme ça qu'il les choisissait.
Le problème pour Kadhafi,
c'est lorsqu'une de ses victimes
tombe enceinte.
Pour régler discrètement la question,
il a fait construire une clinique
dans le sous-sol de l'université,
pour y pratiquer rapidement et en
toute discrétion les avortements.
- La clinique est une maison complète.
Avec de nombreuses chambres,
une salle de bains, une cuisine,
en plus de la clinique.
Nous passions au-dessus
quotidiennement.
Toute l'année et nous n'avons
rien remarqué.
C'est vraiment étrange.
Une université avec tout
le respect qu'on lui doit,
à côté de la faculté de droit
et on trouvait un bordel et une
clinique gynécologique complète.
Vous vous rendez compte ?
Juste à côté de l'université.
Des centaines de femmes ont ainsi
été violées par Kadhafi,
par ses fils et par ses hommes.
Amin attend que ces mercenaires
lui confirment l'assassinat,
de son cousin Charles Arube.
L'enjeu est énorme.
C'est la tentative de coup d'État
la plus dangereuse de son règne.
Mais il est confiant.
Il dispose d'une armée privée
de 18 000 hommes,
qu'il s'est constitué en pillant
le budget de l'État.
Ce sont de véritables escadrons de
la mort qui terrifient tout le pays.
- L'époque d'Amin
était une époque de terreur.
Nous vivions dans la peur,
la peur totale des soldats.
Mohammed Kisambira, a été le banquier
d'Amin avant d'être emprisonné,
comme beaucoup de ses collaborateurs.
- Leur méthode pour tuer les gens,
c'était de les frapper
sur la tête avec un marteau.
La population était
terrifiée en permanence,
par les exactions des soldats d'Amin.
Les gens étaient littéralement
asphyxiés par la peur.
Mais cette fois-ci,
les mercenaires d'Amin ont échoué.
Il vient d'apprendre qu'ils se sont fait
piéger et abattre par les hommes d'Arube.
- Charles Arube
et trois autres Kakwa,
ont déclenché un coup d'État.
Ils se sont emparés des postes clés
de la ville, comme la radio,
la télévision et les principaux
bâtiments du gouvernement.
À ce moment-là, ils pensaient avoir
réussi à prendre le pouvoir.
Charles Arube semble sur
le point de gagner la partie.
Amin rassemble ses troupes
pour lancer une contre-offensive.
- Je me souviens bien de ce jour-là,
notre père est arrivé
avec des revolvers
et puis il est allé dans
le bureau avec ses soldats,
il y avait des soldats
partout dans la maison.
Ils venaient pour une réunion
très importante.
Mais moi, je ne comprenais pas.
Je ne comprenais pas
ce qui se passait.
Amin donne l'ordre
d'encercler le bâtiment,
dans lequel Arube
et ses hommes sont regroupés
et d'attendre ses ordres
avant de passer à l'action.
Cet après-midi,
Staline a convoqué Nikolaï Iejov,
le chef de la police politique.
En grand stratège, il avait
prévu de le sacrifier,
dès le début de la Grande Terreur,
il y a un an et demi.
Il avait tout de suite vu comment
utiliser cet homme cruel,
surnommé le "nain sanguinaire".
Un petit apparatchik prêt à tout pour
gagner la confiance de son maître.
Iejov a supervisé les exécutions
sur tout le territoire de l'Empire
et il n'a pas hésité à torturer
et à tuer de ses propres mains,
dans la prison de la Loubianka.
De juillet 1937
à ce jour de novembre 1938,
Iejov à la tête de la Grande Terreur,
sous les ordres de Staline,
a fait exécuter 770 000 personnes.
Pour l'encourager, Staline en a fait
une des grandes figures du régime.
Ses portraits sont portés
en triomphe par la foule.
Il est applaudi par le Politburo
et part en vacances avec les plus
hauts dignitaires du régime.
Aujourd'hui, Iejov a peur.
Cela fait quelque temps déjà
qu'il a senti venir sa disgrâce.
La seule chose qu'il espère,
c'est sauver sa tête.
Mais Staline a signé sa dernière
liste de condamnés à mort.
Maintenant, il lui faut
un bouc émissaire.
Avec cynisme, il fait pleuvoir
les pires accusations sur Iejov.
Il le traite d'assassin,
de renégat assoiffé de sang.
Il l'accuse d'avoir fait massacrer
des centaines d'innocents à son insu
et d'être un espion
à la solde des Anglais,
des Allemands et des Japonais.
Il le traite même d'alcoolique,
de débauché et de sodomite.
Des chefs d'accusation qui serviront
à le faire condamner.
Iejov ne cherche pas à se justifier.
Il sait qu'une fois que Staline
a décidé de condamner quelqu'un,
rien ne peut l'arrêter,
son sort est scellé.
Mais Iejov n'a pas peur que pour lui,
il a peur aussi
pour sa fille, Natalia,
qui avait dix ans au moment
où il a été arrêté
et qui ignorait tout
des activités de son père.
- Mon père m'adorait.
Je le sentais.
À chaque fois qu'il me voyait,
son visage s'illuminait.
Parfois, encore aujourd'hui,
je me demande comment
dans une seule personne,
il pouvait y avoir
deux êtres si différents.
Quelqu'un d'aussi sanguinaire
d'un côté,
et quelqu'un d'aussi gentil de l'autre.
Une seule fois,
alors qu'elle avait 6 ans,
elle a soupçonné ce que pouvait
être le travail de son père.
- Un jour, on jouait à cache-cache
avec mon cousin
et je suis allée me cacher
dans le cabinet de mon père,
qui avait pour une fois oublié
de le fermer à clé.
Et là, j'ai vu un album.
Par curiosité,
je l'ai ouvert en pensant,
que c'était sûrement
nos photos de famille.
Mais sur toutes les photos,
il y avait des enfants morts.
Empilés les uns sur les autres,
certains sans jambes,
d'autres sans bras.
Quand j'ai vu cette scène d'horreur,
je suis devenue hystérique.
Je suis sortie de la pièce en hurlant.
Mon père n'avait que trois années
d'école pour toute éducation.
C'était vraiment un homme
du peuple qu'on a propulsé,
au plus haut rang du pouvoir.
Et bien sûr, c'est exactement
ce que recherchait Staline,
car il était prêt à exécuter
le moindre de ses ordres aveuglément,
sans se poser de questions.
Mon père a été exécuté
le 4 février 1940.
Dès le premier interrogatoire,
on lui a cassé le bras.
Vous savez, il était
tout petit, tout fin.
Il a demandé que sa famille
soit épargnée
et il a surtout supplié
qu'on m'épargne moi
et qu'on me laisse vivre
en dehors de tout ça.
Vous imaginez sous
la menace de la mort,
alors qu'il avait un pistolet
pointé sur lui,
il a pensé à moi.
Même si l'idée de cette scène
m'a toujours effrayé,
ça m'a aussi touché qu'il pense
à moi dans un moment si dur.
À partir de ce jour-là,
Natalia a été enfermée dans un
orphelinat au nord de la Russie,
jusqu'à sa majorité.
Elle n'a su ce qui était arrivé à son
père que bien des années plus tard.
On lui a interdit à tout jamais
de porter le nom de Iejov.
Aujourd'hui, elle vit seule,
à l'endroit même où elle a été déportée.
Une fois le cas de Iejov réglé,
Staline va, comme tous les jours,
rendre visite à ses enfants.
Ils ont été confiés à des domestiques,
depuis que leur mère, Nadia,
s'est suicidée.
Staline surveille les devoirs et signe
les carnets de notes de Svetlana,
12 ans, et de Vassili, 18 ans.
Il adore tout particulièrement sa fille
et se montre très affectueux.
Il prend le temps de jouer avec
elle et a inventé un jeu,
où c'est elle la patronne
qui lui donne des ordres,
auxquels il obéit avec plaisir.
- Svetlana était une petite fille sage.
Staline aimait Svetlana.
Elle était son espoir.
Elle étudiait bien.
Ils correspondaient toujours ensemble.
Elle lui écrivait des petits mots
et il lui répondait.
Staline l'emmenait toujours avec lui,
en vacances dans le Sud.
Mais Svetlana, qui vit dans un cocon,
se rend compte que de nombreux membres
de la famille et amis ont disparu.
Elle écrira : "Mais où sont-ils
donc tous passés ?
Pourquoi notre maison s'est-elle
vidée de ses habitants ?
Je sentais autour de moi,
et de plus en plus, le vide,
l'absence, le désert d'un monde
où il ne me restait que l'école
et ma nounou.
Dans son camp retranché
sous sa villa forteresse,
Kadhafi a fait construire
un abri antiatomique,
un réseau de 40 km de tunnels enfouis
à six mètres sous terre.
Une véritable ville souterraine,
avec des chambres,
des salons, des salles de sport,
une clinique
et un studio de télévision.
La télévision est son principal
outil de propagande.
Il supervise lui-même
tous les programmes.
Alors qu'il est en train
de visionner le discours,
enregistré quelques heures plus tôt,
son beau-frère Abdallah Senoussi,
le chef de la sécurité intérieure,
arrive pour lui annoncer
une mauvaise nouvelle.
Plus d'un millier de prisonniers
ont saccagé la prison d'Abou Salim.
Ils ont réussi à ouvrir les cellules
des bâtiments 3 et 4 à coups de massue.
Ils sont sur le point de s'évader.
et les gardes n'arrivent plus
à les contenir.
Abou Salim comprend 4 bâtiments.
Fatih Saad, prisonnier
dans le bâtiment 1,
dont les portes n'ont pas été ouvertes,
raconte ce qui s'est passé.
- Les bâtiments 1 et 2 n'ont pas été
ouverts, alors on est resté là.
Ensuite, des négociations ont été
engagées avec Abdallah Senoussi,
mais ça n'a rien donné.
Et puis un ordre est venu
de Kadhafi lui-même.
Il fallait regrouper les prisonniers
des bâtiments 1 et 2
et on nous a transférés
vers une autre prison.
Kadhafi fait évacuer les prisonniers
qui n'ont pas pu se révolter
et ordonne à Senoussi de contenir
pendant ce temps, les insurgés.
L'évacuation va durer toute la nuit.
Il est minuit.
Amin a regagné sa chambre.
Tout s'est déroulé
comme il l'avait prévu.
En effet, en s'emparant des postes
stratégiques de la ville,
Arube a cru qu'il avait
réussi son coup d'État.
Mais il a commis l'erreur
de cesser le combat
et de fêter avec ses hommes
ses victoires dans une caserne.
Pendant ce temps, les hommes d'Amin
se sont déployés dans toute la zone,
en silence, sans que les troupes
d'Arube s'en aperçoivent.
Et ont neutralisé 1 à 1
tous les soldats postés,
à l'extérieur du bâtiment.
Une fois en position,
ils appellent Amin,
pour le prévenir qu'ils sont
prêts à donner l'assaut.
Amine leur demande d'attendre
et parvient à joindre Arube
au téléphone dans la caserne.
- Il a appelé Charles Arube.
Et quand Charles Arube a répondu,
mon père a eu l'impression
que ce cher monsieur était ivre,
qu'il était en train
de célébrer sa victoire.
Ils ont commencé à parler.
Et mon père m'a raconté,
les larmes aux yeux,
ce qui lui a dit.
"Ma mère t'a confié à moi.
Elle m'a demandé de veiller sur toi.
Et malgré ça,
tu veux me prendre le pouvoir ?
Tu me trahis !"
Je vous parle de mon père.
Il était en pleure en se rappelant
cet événement douloureux.
Charles Arube, a répondu :
"C'est une bonne chose que
les chrétiens éduqués gouvernent."
Mon père lui a dit :
"Charles Arube,
regarde par la fenêtre."
Charles Arube avait posté
ses hommes dehors
et quand il a vérifié leur position,
il n'y en avait plus aucun.
Il a vu partout des véhicules
qui n'étaient pas les siens.
Mon père lui a dit : "Tu es encerclé."
Et quand la ligne a été coupée,
il a appelé par radio ses hommes
postés à l'extérieur.
Et ils lui ont dit
qu'ils avaient entendu,
un coup de feu venant de l'intérieur.
Il s'était suicidé.
C'est la douloureuse réalité
avec laquelle nous devons vivre,
nous, les Kakwa.
Car les règles de notre culture
ont été transgressées.
Des frères se sont battus.
Et le sang a coulé.
Qu'il se soit suicidé ou qu'il
ait plus vraisemblablement,
été tué par les hommes d'Amin,
Charles Arube est mort.
Aujourd'hui, Amin a échappé à la plus
dangereuse tentative de putsch,
visant à le renverser.
Mais il lui reste une chose à faire
avant d'en avoir définitivement terminé
avec Charles Arube.
Son corps a été déposé
à la morgue de Kampala.
Amin va maintenant procéder
au rituel des guerriers Kakwa.
- Si vous buvez le sang
de vos victimes,
alors vous serez protégés.
Pour calmer les esprits de ceux
que vous avez tué ou brutalisé,
en goûtant leur sang,
vous atténuez la punition
qu'ils vous réservent.
Amin croyait en ces choses-là.
Personne n'a assisté à la scène,
mais il est probable qu'Amin ait
enfoncé un couteau dans le flanc d'Arube,
pour boire un peu de son sang
et s'incorporer son esprit,
afin de l'empêcher de se venger.
Après une journée bien remplie,
Staline s'allonge sur son vieux canapé
en écoutant son morceau préféré,
le Concerto pour piano
numéro 23 de Mozart.
Seul au petit matin
dans son immense datcha,
le dictateur peut être satisfait.
En ce 24 novembre 1938,
Staline a éliminé tous ses ennemis.
Il est désormais le seul véritable
patron de l'Union soviétique.
Kadhafi attend la confirmation de
l'évacuation des bâtiments 1 et 2.
Senoussi, le chef de la sécurité,
l'appelle.
L'évacuation est terminée.
Les prisonniers des bâtiments 3 et 4,
ceux qui se sont révoltés,
sont maintenant massés dans la cour.
Ils sont déchaînés.
La situation est explosive.
Il faut faire vite.
Kadhafi ordonne l'exécution des
1270 prisonniers d'Abou Salim.
Il est 8 h 30,
postés en haut des toits de la prison,
les soldats commencent à tirer
sur les prisonniers pris au piège.
- Soudain, les militaires
sont arrivés
et ils ont commencé à tirer
à l'intérieur de la prison,
tuant plus de 1200 prisonniers.
Et le massacre a duré des heures.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on
peut faire en quelques minutes.
Ils ont tiré jusqu'à ce
que tout le monde soit mort.
Finalement, la mort de Kadhafi
est directement liée,
à cette décision de commettre
un massacre à Abou Salim.
Parce que c'est l'étincelle
qui a déclenché,
la révolution de 2011.
En effet, en février 2011,
en plein printemps arabe,
les mères, sœurs et veuves
des hommes tués à Abou Salim,
descendent dans la rue et manifestent
pour que la vérité soit faite,
sur les circonstances
exactes du massacre.
La police intervient
et tire sur la foule,
ce qui déclenchera les 1ᵉʳˢ affrontements
et le début de la révolution,
qui embrasera toute la Libye
pendant neuf mois
et aboutira au lynchage
de Mouammar Kadhafi.
Des années plus tôt,
dans l'un de ses textes,
Kadhafi avait écrit :
"Que j'aime la liberté des foules,
leur élan enthousiaste après
la rupture des chaînes,
lorsqu'elles lancent un cri de joie
et chantent après
les plaintes de la peine.
Mais comme je les crains
et les redoute,
et comme elles sont cruelles
dans les moments de colère.
Elles ont comploté contre Hannibal
et lui ont fait boire du poison.
Elles ont brûlé Savonarole
sur le bûcher,
envoyé Danton à l'échafaud,
fracturé les mâchoires de Robespierre,
traîné le corps de Mussolini
dans les rues,
craché à la figure de Nixon.
Kadhafi est mort à 69 ans.
Il a régné 42 ans sur la Libye.
Après avoir fui l'Ouganda en 1979,
lors de l'invasion
de l'armée tanzanienne,
Idi Amin Dada finira sa vie
en exil en Arabie saoudite.
Il dira dans le dernier
entretien qu'il a donné.
"Je n'ai pas de remords,
je n'ai que de la nostalgie."
Il mourra en 2003 à 75 ans,
sans jamais avoir été inquiété.
Son règne a duré huit ans et fait
plus de 300 000 victimes.
Aujourd'hui,
l'Ouganda n'est plus une dictature,
mais les salles de réclusion
et de torture,
où tant de personnes ont trouvé
la mort sont toujours là,
abandonnées dans la forêt.
Le 1ᵉʳ mars 1953,
Staline, enfermé dans son bureau,
ne se manifeste pas
de toute la journée.
Son entourage n'ose pas le déranger.
Lorsqu'en fin de journée, le coursier
du Kremlin entre dans le bureau,
il trouve Staline inconscient,
gisant à terre,
frappé d'une commotion cérébrale.
Il a 75 ans.
Staline mourra comme il a gouverné,
seul, dans son bureau.
L'homme qui a été à l'origine
de plus de 20 millions de morts,
meurt au sommet du pouvoir.
Pleuré par des millions de Soviétiques
et même par une partie de ses victimes.
Il a bâti un système qui va lui
survivre plus de 35 ans.